good morning as we have already stated a
few days ago the European Union has
activated all its crisis management
mechanisms in particular in the field of
public health and also in the field of
civil protection and crisis coordination
so far as you know the certain actions
already took place I would like to
mention in this context the successful
repatriation of over 500 citizens of
European Union from China to their
places to their countries of origin in
European Union we have offered China
assistance this offer was already made
by the president from the lion in her
discussion over the phone with Prime
Minister Li Keqiang
of China we are in constant contact with
the Chinese authorities in order to see
how we can jointly in cooperation stop
the spread of this virus now is the time
to to pull our forces together now is
the time to work together now is the
time to do everything we can jointly to
stop this epidemics we are working day
and night this center here works 24/7 we
are working all the time on preparedness
and on possible responses with a view to
have all the new member states in a good
state of preparedness and in order to
exchange information coordinate our
efforts and see to it that this
epidemics would stop sooner rather than
later it is possible though that before
things get better they will still or
could still get somewhat
worse but this will not discourage us
this will only motivate us more so that
we are better prepared and we coordinate
our action with the view to stop this
epidemics I would not be ready to answer
a few questions of yours the decision on
travel restrictions is the decision to
be taken by member state what the
European Commission has done together
with European external Action Service it
has advised all its staff to postpone
all non-essential travel to and from
China until further notice then it is up
to Member States to decide on about what
they will do with regard to this issue
you are aware of the recommendation by
the World Health Organization that
travel restrictions would not be
necessary that's recommendation from one
side as I said it is up to the Member
States of the opinion to decide on the
measures they deem necessary our
ambition is that this is done in a
coordinated manner and this is the role
of the European Union to coordinate
actions by EU Member States in this
field such advice is not yet offered now
is it worrying for you and second would
the Commission support an extraordinary
meeting of the ministers of health it is
rumour Rumour stated that it will be
this week
situation definitely is worrisome this
is Buddhism epidemic this is a serious
danger for Public Health
this virus as you know spreads with
great speed so measures have to be taken
and we are trying to see that they are
taken in a coordinated manner and in
this context we also the Commission also
very much supports the convening of
extraordinary Council of health
ministers which is supposed to take
place later this week do you believe the
numbers coming from China are accurate
about total deaths we have no reasons
not to believe those numbers since this
issue has come to the attention of the
international community I can say that
the cooperation between the European
Commission and Chinese authorities has
been good ask for a special summit about
the minister's health ministers with
Grazia preparation do you need we need a
special summit and that a second
question we are sending more material
medical material in China on the second
issue yes China made it known that it
would need personal protective equipment
like gloves protective masks and
protective gowns and we are in the
process of mapping the capacities that
the European Union member states can
offer and we will arrange such a
provision of such assistance to China
some of it has already was a very sent
to China about 12 tons from Germany and
France on a flight that was co-financed
by by the European Commission on the
first issue the extraordinary Health
Council as I said the Commission
supports the convening of such council
it will take place according to our
information at the end of later this
week
we believe that such a council meeting
is useful in order to arrange for a
coordinated action of EU Member States
but we have a centre here what is
exactly doing that so we really need
this Emergency Response Coordination
centre is only one of the tools that we
are using in this I think it is still
important and useful that the health
ministers themselves sit together
discuss the situation exchange
information on the measures they have
taken and see how further coordinated
measures can be taken the cost is of
secondary nature for the Commission in
this issue the public health is of
paramount concern there are various
possibilities for for the health
ministers to look into I cannot
speculate what kind of concrete measures
they will take you know that member
states have taken so far a number of
measures themselves some more than the
others what is our belief is that this
issue is best tackled in a coordinated
manner and that's where we see the value
of an extraordinary Council of health
ministers
you have a picture from the scientific
community I mean is there any progress
in the vaccine research as you know the
commission has allocated 10 million euro
last month for the research of vaccine
this funding can support several
projects it is now the process is now
open for the projects to be submitted
and I hope that this contribution from
the European Commission will help
achieve what we all desire and that is
to get the effective vaccine soon
partner with Europe how is the EU
preparing for what could potentially be
a disruption to supply chains to
medications to good this is a serious
issue supply chains we all know our
global nowadays and most of them have an
important element important part in in
China proper we know that with regard to
this epidemics the Chinese economy the
Chinese factories are affected and that
that by definition also it affects the
global chains and global economy this is
a serious issue but as I said already
earlier at this time our paramount
priority our paramount concern should be
devoted to public health measures and
the economic consequences are of course
secondary although not unimportant thank
you
[Music]